we're joined here on a very special
friday with a very special guest josh
how's it going man
i'm doing well yourself fired it's good
to be here yeah man doing well doing
well bro
so 38 viewers on the live stream let's
go get the likes of inshallah it helps
the viewers helps the videos and
algorithm but before we get right into
it josh tell me a little bit about why
you reached out to us a little bit about
your journey bro just so the viewers
know where you are
okay so um
so a little background about myself i'm
from south africa and i'm 19 years old
and i'm currently studying in the united
states and i'm about to go to college in
august
um so last year january
i went back home
and i was
very really i had no direction in my
spiritual journey you know because i'm a
christian i was raised in a christian
household
but i i wasn't fulfilled you know i was
looking for answers things a lot of
contradictions that i came about
and i was just looking for
you know the truth
so this is a funny story so i'm on a on
a friday friday afternoon
my grandfather asked me to go to the
butchery to get some meat because we
were
my family was coming over you know
having a small family gathering
and um
there was this man i forgot his name was
his name was jameel
as soon as i went into the store and i
told him i was like so jamil
what religion are you and then he says
i'm a muslim and he tells me about islam
just a little bit we didn't go into
detail
and then i told him that like i'm like
look
i'm a christian but
i'm just not fulfilled with my spiritual
self and i don't know what to do
so out of the blue he just gave me a
quran and he said here go read this
right and then obviously i was still
skeptical i was like um
i just don't know if i should do this or
not
you know um and i was obviously still
young and naive you know i was only like
17 18.
and then i went back home
um and this was a month before i came to
the states and i spoke to my parents
about it and they said no don't do this
you know we've been we've been christian
all our lives and we really don't want
you to go on this journey
and
um
i don't know how to take it you know
because i feel like they were
restricting me because with a person
like myself
i want to learn new things
i want to be a very open-minded person
and i don't want to stay in the same
stage in life over and over
so
i went to the states and it was a body
be ramadan
and
i phoned jameel and he said look try out
ramadan and learn about islam
and just try your best and fast
so i fasted all 30 days and i was still
playing sport
it was it was tough
it was mentally challenging but i still
got through it
so
after
after ramadan i went back home and i
told my parents like you know i did
ramadan i want to do my shahada right
away let's go find our nearest muscle we
can so we can go ahead with the
preparations
and then they they looked at me and they
they thought i was crazy or whatever
but um
that really put me down and i think
throughout ramadan i i was i was happy
you know i was um
i wouldn't say i was fulfilled entirely
but i was i was happy and
while i was learning about islam
i just felt drawn to it like i just
wanted to keep on learning about it and
i didn't want to stop
and
a year goes by
in which now i'm here today thank god
but um
i found you guys's channel so i was lit
i was listening to i don't know if you
guys are aware of
mufti mink i don't know if that's his
name
and i watched a bit of these interviews
and i watched a little bit of alidawah i
don't know if you have also aware of him
so i watched their youtube channels and
um
something just led me to your guys's
channel and
i
want to
ask you guys a few questions so i think
that's why i'm here today
of course man i'm hamdulillah so for the
viewers that don't know the backstory uh
we got a comment from brother josh about
a few days ago on youtube right
basically had like a very summer
summarized version you know what he's
saying right now in the life
and i took it upon myself as soon as i
read it i was like bro let's get him on
the podcast if he's done you know let's
talk to him let's let's hook him up
let's see what's good and uh
when you mentioned uh when we first
spoke you said that you know you're okay
for the live stream you have some
questions right
bro i didn't even want to hear the
questions i was so excited i was just
like hyped let's get the podcast going
let's let's show your journey to the
world and now it's time and and i hope
you have your questions ready bro i do i
do
all right then with that with that being
said bro hit us up what are the
questions okay so my first question is
which book should i read to expand my
knowledge about islam and the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
[Music]
so when it comes to learning about islam
and learning about the life of the
prophets upon him those are almost
almost too
similar but different things and the
reason i say that is because although
you learn about islam reading the life
of the prophet peace be upon him
you won't exactly get an in-depth
teaching
because the seerah is not a
book of you know kind of
step one through a hundred on what
al-qaeda is what our belief is what our
practices are and all of that there are
thousands of a hadith and there are many
volumes of books about the life of the
prophet if you want to read about the
life of the prophet
uh if you do want to read instead of
watching this into a lecture then the
sealed nectar is probably the most
famous the most popular
seerah book a book on the life of the
prophet peace and blessings be upon him
if you want to learn about what we
believe and why we practice then there
are books from our scholars like imam
shafi
there are books from imam nawabi there
are books from
uh from uh imam abu harif
and other scholars but i wouldn't
recommend jumping into the scholars work
i would recommend something a little
more baseline a little more fundamental
so like maybe like the fundamentals of
islam the fundamentals of belief in
islam and so on and so forth but the
absolute best way
to learn islam
and to feel that
connection with god in your heart
is to read the quran and i'm sure you
have maybe twice three times allah adam
i don't know how many times you read the
quran but reading the quran
will give you that connection with allah
so i'm going to suggest two things
that you read quran regularly in a
reflective manner in a reflective state
that when you read a few verses
you sit there and you reflect on what it
could mean and you'll find that it could
mean more things than it appears to in
the beginning it could relate to more
things in life than you may have thought
initially when you know you first read
it
says
he says
those who believe in whose heart are
content with the remembrance of allah
indeed with the remembrance of allah the
hearts find contentment so that ease
that contentment that you are looking
for that we as human beings look for
strive for because we're created to want
to have this
is a contentment from remembering allah
from remembering god so reading the
quran and reflecting on it we'll do that
and then i'm going to recommend that you
have some brothers like you have here
insha allah that you can reach out to
that can teach you about islam because
the islamic method of teaching is that
of a student
and their mentor a student and their
teacher so not so you don't just learn
the fundamentals and the belief and the
practices from them but you also learn
the mannerisms and the character from
them
yes i understand um because it's also
hard for me where i am now um i think
there's
there's only one
muslim person here so it's hard to learn
from multiple people you know yeah and
um yeah
so that's that's the hard part about
learning like the mannerisms and how
you act on a day-to-day basis
yeah i see do you not have a masjid in
your area
it's the nearest one is two hours away
wow yeah let's get you a message down
there inshallah yay bro yeah but that
that aside bro these things are gonna
come naturally over time me rami and
we've experienced like a honing of these
skills over time alhamdulillah and it
just comes very slowly but in terms of
quran what i wanted to add before
brother angel jumps in is one thing that
truly helped me and uh my mind went
blank i don't know if rami already
mentioned this or not but
go into it as if allah god is speaking
to you in the quran go into it as if
allah is directly speaking to you you
know and everything you're hearing is is
the word of god which it is right but if
you if you go into it just thinking oh
it's just a book it's just a religious
book it's a religious text or it's kind
of like the gospels then you're not
going to get the same effect but if you
go into it with the frame of mind of
what it truly is that it's the word of
allah it's a complete game changer bro
yeah
and i think the biggest thing that i had
and it's something that i've
just recently kind of started doing
is when you read the quran like you know
when you read any book
you you might read
over a few lines and then you forget
what you read so then you go back and
then you read the same lines over again
um
subhanallah it's
it's actually
quite crazy how that is
and how perfect it is because
in the quran like
when you do this when that happens and
you have to like come back and then read
certain lines again
each time that you do that it's almost
like the intensity
of what's being said actually becomes
greater and greater and it'll get to
points where you almost feel like
like god is just straight up just
yelling everything out
not a bad way but
like the words are so powerful that it
feels like it's just being yelled out to
you
so
okay don't be afraid when you're reading
it to like
you know let's say you read two three
lines like stop and then go back and
read the same two three lines or read
like another line again like it
don't try to rush through it don't try
to read as much as you can as possible
like a lot of people
they'll go into ramadan and they'll say
you know i'm going to read the entire
quote and this month
which you know like that's beautiful you
know
there's nothing wrong with that
but there's also like you said the
reflective way we read it and you really
take the time with it and you gotta
understand like
we work off
um
it's like it's like a wave you know like
you're in the ocean
a wave doesn't have a peak 24 7 you have
like the wave that goes up and the way
that comes down and then you have like
the bottom portion until the next peak
comes
that's kind of how it is for us like
sometimes we'll be able to read
a lot at once and retain and actually
like be reflective and gather inside
from it and then sometimes we won't be
able to really read that much and that's
all right we might only be able to get
like
one sentence one ayat
right and that's it that's okay that's
that's exactly how it should be in that
time because like bro there was there
were months at a time where i would only
read like one sentence or two sentences
per day
but like i would really reflect on those
one or two sentences and then there's
times where i'll read like
several pages
per day and then really reflect on that
so you just gotta
you know don't don't
don't try to be
[Music]
obsessive
with like trying to finish x amount when
you're reading it just take your time
with it bro yeah bro and one thing i
wanted to add to i know we took almost
10 minutes for your first question bro
so i'll try to be a little more concise
you probably since we're very
enthusiastic bro about islam so we'll
try to be a little more submitted
because i know you got a bunch of
questions
yeah um also don't worry because i'm
still taking notes while you guys are
speaking so
no there's no way
all right what's the next question um
the next question so
how
does dating work um
in islam um
because if i was to do my shahada and
convert right and i'm about to go into
college and you know as you get in
college you know
if experimentations are done you know
there's a lot of
natural obligations as anger will say
going on
and
um if you don't date right how do you
get married and
yeah that's i think i'm gonna leave it
there if you don't date how do you get
married
yo so
i'll jump in first all right so first
off
you know i'm sure you've heard that like
in islam it's it's
encouraged for the
the young to marry young
yeah
right
so
this this is should be done you know i i
agree hundred percent but
coming from the lego someone who's
reverted not too long ago like almost
two years ago actually
take the time to like
focus on yourself
and heal and learn islam and get your
connection with allah before
you start looking for women
because in islam we have this prayer
known as the isla
prayer and
it's the prayer of guidance
not anyone could pray that it's too hard
to pray
but
i found that like the more in tune with
allah that i am
and and the more that i've been like
working on myself and just healing from
all the things and and not really
doing things that pull me away from
allah
the deeper i can go into that prayer and
the more guidance that i get from that
prayer and the answers that i get from
that prayer
um so it's not to say that you won't it
won't be answered it's not to say that
you know what like it's the moment you
become a muslim
you could probably find a wife you
probably couldn't man
like a lot of the best you probably
could but i've just come to find that
like you know what you want to take care
of yourself
and your connection with the love first
and then allah will provide you
with the woman that you know
will be good for you inshallah
fire bro
thank you bro i had nothing else to say
aside from oh no bro pretty concise
really good answer masha allah now i
want to touch on the the a little bit uh
so how do we date in islam it's funny
because
you'll find even muslims use this word
date
i know
we uh we're we're dating now or whatever
yeah dating what does that mean
uh so we don't date in islam at all
sometimes people use the term to refer
to
the
state that they're in before they get
married which is getting to know each
other which is recommended by the
prophet peace be upon him there is a
hadith where a a man who went to the
prostitute and he said i'm getting
married the prophet asked have you seen
her
he said no and the process said go see
her
so we're encouraged to go see those were
you know gonna be married to there's no
such thing as uh just uh kind of forced
marriages like oh you know your
wedding's tomorrow your mom comes to you
like hey your wedding's tomorrow you're
marrying your cousin well that's not
islamic just i wanted to slip that in
there so how do we date if you see
someone like let's see
let's say you see a sister that you want
to marry
you don't go to her be like yo shawty
what's up you look fine today you know
can i holla at you something
you go to here you say or maybe even
slip for a note and you say in a very
modest way alaikum sister you know i'd
like to get to know you for marriage uh
is your father around as you go around
like to talk
be a man and he go ask for you know the
man in her family basically
and uh if that man deems you worthy then
insha'allah if he is a good man
he sees you have good character good
religion he sees that you'd be a good
fit for his daughter
and she's interested then he'll allow it
and you guys will start talking
so under supervision of you know her
brother or maybe in some cases the
sister as well
and you'll start talking getting to know
her because you don't need to date to be
able to marry someone believe it or not
you don't need to be able to take them
for a physical test run to you know
touch them and be like yeah this feels
right stuff
you don't need that like we're all
sexual animals 100
if you're attracted to someone and you
connect with them
you have the same belief
and you you know you you know that
you guys can be intimate in the future
once you're married there's not going to
be a problem as long as you guys are
compatible inshallah
okay
all right you get you get to really know
someone too this is this is the last
like slide in you get to really know
someone when you take sex out of the
equation
like in the west
um i don't know if it's like this in in
africa but
in the west for the most part like
people they they do the test runs so to
say like how rami said but these test
runs man they cloud your judgment
over the person right so it's like
you might there might be these red flags
that are popping up but you won't be
able to catch on to the red flags
because your
your head is clouded with
the good feelings of the uh physical
intimacy
but when that physical intimacy is not
there
well now you see everything very clearly
and if
there are red flags and there are
certain things that this person is doing
that you know what you really don't
you really don't agree with like you
know this is not something that you
would actually want an apartment yeah
it's very easy for you to see and once
you catch on like you can cut it off
right there and there's no hard feeling
because again like there's there's no
attachment really you guys are still
just talking without any physical
intimacy so there's a reason for
everything though the more you get into
this time you start to realize that
i know i know you're growing up in in
like you're like here in the west now in
america
and you see like hookup culture you know
people are having sex and they say oh
there's no we're not going to get
attached you know we're just hooking up
we're not trying to you know have any
emotions bro that doesn't exist bro
let's be honest bro that doesn't exist
yeah i don't have sex without someone of
an emotional connection and in islam
that does not come until after nikka and
there's a lot of scholars too right i'm
not a scholar so i can't tell you you
know verify the authenticity of this but
i heard a lot of scholars say you
shouldn't even fall in love with the
person until after nikka
because a lot of people make that trap
of getting too attached before nikka and
then they were other red flags too just
like on house stains
yeah and on that point i don't find it
very healthy because it's not good for
your soul because imagine you're
sleeping around with a lot of people now
you're leaving your soul with this
person with this person with that person
both ties are a thing you know and uh
yeah i don't
i don't want to
be associated with that kind of
lifestyle you know 100 100
yeah you already know
what's the next one bro
um so this one's for uncle um how did
your family process the fact that you
converted to islam
and it was a it was a gradual process
what was the final bit of the question
um and how
how did you break it to them like how
how did you tell them that like look
this is
what i'm about to do with my life
yeah so
uh i told them after i became muslim
i i didn't consult them
like ask them like how they felt i just
you know i felt it and i was like yeah i
guess i'm a muslim i took my shahada
with this beautiful brother right here
fayette he actually guided me through it
and i bless him
but then when i told my family i first
started with my mom
and when i broke it to her
we were just walking and then one day i
was like you know what kind of telling
her some things about the quran like you
know what's crazy like in the quran it
says this this and that and then she's
like oh like that's that's actually
pretty amazing i agree with that i agree
with that everything i kept throwing up
she was like i agree with it i was like
i was like yeah that's pretty wild isn't
it and she's like yeah i was like yeah i
just want to let you know that i'm a
muslim now
and then she's like bro she's she stayed
quiet and she didn't really know how to
react and then when we got in the car
like shortly after to go somewhere
she was like oh
don't tell anyone like
you make sure that you keep it a secret
i'm like why she's like oh because
you're going to be targeted like
they're going to come after you and i'm
like
mom like i love you but you just
what you think right now is just the uh
the misconceptions
of what people think muslims are you
know we don't have to say it on stream
on air for you to know what i'm talking
about
yeah
but yeah that's what she thought it was
you know over time she
she uh started to
accept it more and more and
um you know she's with it
my dad
my dad he kind of like
he accepted it from the goal
but later on like he kind of questioned
me about it because there was a point
where
we were at a family gathering and
everyone was like doing shots
like shout out to alcohol and you know
as a muslim you don't drink alcohol
and then like
they were basically trying to like
pure push me like oh come like take this
shot i'm like nah like i'm good
and like why i was like you know why i
know why i was like because i'm a muslim
and as a muslim we do not drink alcohol
and then they they say kind of quiet
and i think my mom and my dad were like
oh like why do you have to do that why
you have to ruin the vibe i was like
listen i'm not ruining anything like if
y'all want to do that like that's
y'all's decision this is my decision
this is what i'm gonna do and then from
there my dad was questioning me about
islam
and he asked me like why why did i
choose islam and i told him exactly why
and once i told him he was just like
stay quiet he's like
all right
um and then from there bro like
you know my sister and my brother
obviously gonna accept it like what are
they gonna say you know
but the the biggest thing that i can say
here is like
once you start to
you know follow islam once you start to
believe more you start to practice more
and all this stuff once they see that
you're in it 100
they will follow you know they may not
follow in the sense of them becoming
muslims
i mean allah knows best god knows best
but they will follow in the sense that
they will support you
and they respect the fact that i i'm a
muslim yeah
yeah and it goes it goes with ending in
life like people people don't believe
people don't believe what you're saying
until you believe it
so it's like once you're about it then
they're gonna be about it it's just it's
how it is man with everything
okay
um so my next question is what is the
difference between
a shia and a sunni
rami bro go right in
if i was um if i was to convert um do i
have to
um and do i have to choose one
how does it work
it's a good one it's a good question
actually this question comes up so much
by both muslims and non-muslims that i
asked my sheikh about it just to be
extra sure
that i'm giving the right answer here
so
the difference between the shias and the
sunnis
uh basically is a political difference
it's not a theo it wasn't a theological
one it wasn't one in belief it wasn't
even really one in practice in the
beginning it was literally just a
political one where as muslims we have a
khalifa we have a an islamic leader
who governs the islamic state islamic
nation and is obliged basically to take
care of them and lead them under the
laws of god subhanallah
we believe
that after the prophet peace be upon him
passes away
that
the ummah the entire nation has a right
to select a leader for themselves we
believe that this is a god-given right
and we have the hadith too
to prove that they believe that it
should have been ali
bro bro quick context when you say we
you're talking about us
yeah yeah because a lot of people are
wondering which side are you guys on
i'm going to get into that i shouldn't
be which side and this and that i'll get
that
for clarifying that so yeah we are
sunnis believe that the muslim um the
nation all the muslims get to vote on a
khalifa and the shias believe that this
is somebody who was appointed and that
the person who was supposed to be
appointed is
ali
who was related to the prophet
and we're not doubting that ali would
have been a great first khalifa second
khalifa khalifa
as sunnis we don't we don't have a
problem saying that the first four
khalifas could have been in any order
it could have been uthman and then abu
bakr then um
either one of them would have done a
fantastic job of being the first second
third or fourth the way i ended up going
was it was abu bakr then omar then uman
and then ali
so what started as a political dispute
and there have been wars and stuff
between muslims after the death of the
prophet peace be upon him which he
actually prophesies and talked about um
like
fighting with this person and this
person fighting that person and the
fighting within the muslim after he
passes away
and there is a beautiful hadith which
really clarifies this for the prophet
peace be upon him
he prays he makes a dua to allah and he
asks o allah do not allow my my ummah to
be overtaken by another nation and then
allah accepted that and he said yeah
allah do not let my my ummah be
overtaken by like some kind of natural
disaster and allah accepted that
and then the prophet saw he asked oh
allah do not allow my ummah to be
divided and fall into sectarianism
and fall into different sects and fight
and stuff and allah
said that no this is their test
so the prophet peace be upon him knew
exactly what was going to happen and now
it's something that has become
theological later on now the as they
have different theological beliefs and
some of them take it to the extent of
saying certain things that take them out
of the fold of islam they will say the
angel gabriel made a mistake and went to
muhammad sallallahu salaam instead of
ali
and they completely
changed things around so as a sunni
obviously i'm biased and being
biased isn't always bad as long as it's
towards the truth
and you know we can talk about offstream
why more specifically but if you accept
islam today insha'allah you will be a
sunni now
is not muslim that's not true
and if you were to in my opinion uh
people differ on this in my opinion in
my teacher's opinion if you were to
accept islam and start practicing like a
shia we still believe you would be a
muslim but we believe that you would be
misguided in some ways
so we don't say that shias are not
muslim they are muslim but we believe we
have we believe that they have some
things wrong there are some shias again
that have certain beliefs that take them
out of the fold of islam but there are
some people that claim to be sunni
that uh have you know beliefs that take
them out of the full snap as well so i
hope that makes sense inshallah yes it
does yeah
so bro just to keep it very simple
just become muslim
like don't don't worry about sex and all
that stuff like listen i'm two years in
romp listen romney's saying the truth
but i'm two years in i don't consider
myself any
anything i'm i'm a muslim that's it i'm
a muslim
and and that's all that really needs to
be
especially for a reaver bro in the
beginning
you know like develop your connection
with the love first
that's that's the main thing though i
always tell people that's too like the
the sunni sect itself i don't even
consider it a sect bro i consider it
just what on house saying what does
brother sing that you're a muslim see
the fact is the prophet saw islam came
and all the prophets came all the
messengers of allah came
and to give them tawheed the message of
one true god and to just be guided to
the right path the straight path right
this by definition makes you a muslim
but
because of difference in opinion because
of people think thinking you know they
make their their ways and desires and
their own ideologies the right path
because of all of this we have what we
have today right we
protect in islam we have ahmed is who i
don't even consider muslim to be honest
we have shia we have sufi we have uh
ismaili we have all of this right but
because of all of this that's why we
have sunni right because we don't want
to make sects but we have sunni just to
show okay because y'all already have all
these sects we're going to make this one
just to make like this orthodox pure
unadulterated unfiltered legit version
of islam
okay
um my next question is what is sharia um
i haven't
um i wasn't able to
[Music]
it was it was kind of confusing for me
so i just want your full insight on what
that is
all right another another great question
because a lot of people in the west are
like oh they're trying to bring their
sharia allah here they're trying to cut
off our hands with sri allah and well
okay relax
sharia
is just the islamic law in general
encompassed within the sharia
are multiple things there is the
personal
rulings
as an individual for example um
trying to think of a good one
within the
you as a muslim you're obligated to pray
five times a day right yeah
so that is within the
islam and some scholars say that the
term which is like the rulings and
sharia which is like the rulings of
islam
are synonymous they're the same exact
thing so there are like i said multiple
types the personal one
then there's the communal one the
communal rulings and obligations and the
obligations in the laws that kind of
come from above top down or from allah
that apply to all of humanity on a
communal level so that does include
things like capital punishment
and lashing for slandering and forcing a
man to you know give money to take care
of his children and things like that
because he's obligated to and he's able
to but maybe he's just neglecting them
and so on and so forth
but it's not this kind of
crazy barbaric thing that people try and
portray in the west
not not paying income tax is a part of
sharia law
you know having access to public
resources is the part of sharia allah
having public health care is a part of
sharia allah
you know giving 2.5 approximately of
your savings
of your excessive wealth
is a part of allah that goes to the poor
taking care of the orphans and the poor
you know that's the part of sharia allah
so sharia law is so encompassing it's
literally all the rulings in islam that
we are obliged to follow as muslims
okay
um
this is the second last question
um would it be beneficial for me to
learn the arabic language yes
i think on behalf of everyone here when
i say yes we are very very firm on that
yeah but again it's it's become awesome
first of all like that's something that
comes later like i'm learning arabic
right now so it's okay it's all a
learning process you do it in steps
yeah
but i'm going to tell you the advice
that i gave on her bro and again no
pressure bro if you don't think you're
ready you know but there was this time
when me and anna were talking just like
ah mentioned in the beginning and he was
getting curious into islam and he was
feeling that pull and he was getting all
everything was kind of you know clicking
for him and he was ready and i gave this
advice to a lot of people too they're
like how do i know this is the time i
don't know is the time let me at least
do this first let me at least do that
first right
and i'm not saying this is a scare
tactic bro so take this out of love when
i tell you this right now but you really
don't know what's gonna happen when you
step out the door
you really don't know if you're gonna
make it until that day where you
you let go of your ego and you say the
shahada or you make things right with
allah
when it's all said and done right
saying that oh allah if only you gave me
another day or if only gave me another
year if only you let me know break up
with my girlfriend and then make it
right
bro when it's all said and done that
that's not going to fly as an excuse bro
saying oh if only this if only that what
matters is what did you do with the time
that you were given bro so delaying it
any second more than necessary i think
is something we shouldn't do and that
advice usually i give it to everyone bro
yeah 100 and uh
as a muslim as someone who's you know
born into islam and someone who is
actually arab who's palestinian i don't
speak arabic silk i'm still learning
alhamdulillah and i'm 21 years old so
it's natural it's normal it's okay most
people in the world don't speak arabic
but that that honestly has never really
stopped anyone from becoming muslim and
if it was something that was
prerequisite to islam then allah would
have made it prerequisite that you need
to speak arabic in order to be muslim
but he doesn't he says you need to
believe xyz
you need to testify that belief
and that's it
that's it and bro josh one more thing
too islam was revealed over 23 years i
don't know if you know this but it took
23 years for the full quran to be
revealed for all of islam to be
delivered right so if you look at this
right the muslims at the time bro they
were constantly changing constantly
adapting constantly learning new things
right there was never like this just
here's all of islam take it right out
right off the bat you know it was never
like that off the rip so it was always
constant adaptation constant learning
right so this whole thing is a lifelong
process bro there's people i know that
are in their 60s 70s 80s now that
they're finally getting religious
they're finally learning arabic they're
finally getting on deemed so that's the
thing bro i'd rather you take the first
step then take no step but then once you
get it bro everything usually falls into
line naturally bro and it's a natural
course that's the sustainable course
where you don't think you're doing too
much more than you can handle
bro and
i'm gonna say this here because
it's very important but
before i became muslim like i had the
experience that i and i won't get into
the experience because
well i i've said it multiple times and i
have a video in my channel where i'm
like you know talking about my
experience um but nonetheless it was a
very powerful experience it was one that
that it was like once you experience it
you have zero doubt whatsoever
that it's the truth
you know and and i had this experience i
told fired about it
and then i told fire well you know what
in islam it's haram to get tattoos
i want to tattoo my entire body so i'm
i'm going to become a muslim
after i tattoo my entire body
may god forgive me but i was saying that
and i said it to him and
like him and being a good friend he was
just like
he was like yeah okay like i see where
you're coming from but then he made the
point that he brought up to you were you
like well what if
you know what if you
you end up dying
before that even happens
and i brought up the thing is like oh
well god knows what's in my heart god
knows that i was a muslim and then he
had said like yeah like in your heart
you could have already took in your
shahada but you haven't
put it into existence you haven't set it
on your lips and when you say it on your
lips that's what causes like the whole
chain of events to start occurring like
the real changes
just start occurring
you know so
it has to be in both that has been your
heart and it has to be on your tongue
okay thank you thank you thank you
um
so
uh
last question
[Music]
do i have to change my name to a muslim
name if i revert convert no no brother
that is one of the biggest
misconceptions before the two amigos
here jump in on hell until this day
hasn't changed his name right
um from what i know bro secretly bro he
could be living a complete double life
that me and ramy have no idea about
behind the scenes right but we can only
go based off of what he tells us
and i'm just playing but uh you know
me and rami we got more practicing on
the later in the life right but we were
born muslims most of the rivers i know
they didn't change the name changing
your name from what i understand right
and you guys can correct me if i'm wrong
it's just something to give you that
muslim identity it's not you know
jurisprudentially obligation you know
it's not obligatory it's not something
that you have to do it's not an
obligation on you um it's some it's kind
of like when when someone becomes muslim
a lot of rivers i know they start
wearing like the thobes you know or they
start wearing the the the kofi the hat
like like angel's wearing you know it's
just something you do just to identify
after being muslim it's kind of like
when you go to uni or college in the
states you know you wear like the you
were the your your sports team your
school's team you know on on like a
t-shirt or a hoodie right it's just
something just just to get that click
just to get that affiliation that
identity but it's not something that you
have to do right
yeah
um forgive me i just thought about one
last question
of course
there are five laws of islam right
there's your iman there's a lot there's
zakat and there's hajj i don't know if i
said them right
um so what happens to a muslim who does
not follow one of the pillars
so what i need muslim other forces
go on go on my bad what's the rest of
the question
yeah that was that was the whole
question okay i thought just
so any muslim who doesn't fulfill
the five obligations it depends if it's
the first one
of belief and test testimony of there's
no god worthy worship except allah and
the prophet muhammad is the last and
final messenger of of god or last
prophet messenger of god
if they don't believe that then they're
not a muslim to begin with because you
cannot be a muslim without believing
that it's explicitly mentioned in the
quran and to delete disbelieve in the
quran you wouldn't be a muslim to begin
with so if that's you know there then we
have four which are actions
even the testimony of faith scholars say
it's an action but it's this it's also
the belief in touch behind it which is
with all deeds
so when it comes to prayer charity
fasting and going for hajj
it's
part of me are you talking about giving
zakat too
did i mention
you said yeah yeah no so just the the
five after the shot
yeah the four after the shahada before
after this
yeah yeah
so prayer charity fasting and had
when it comes to these if a muslim is
able to and they don't they are sinful
because they are obligatory these are
things that allah has prescribed for
muslims to do
and he's prescribed them for us and he
loves them
uh when they're done allah there's a
hadith
that is called the hadith meaning
said it so the prophet peace be upon him
says of that allah
has said
i believe it's a hadith it might not be
but regardless the hadith where it says
that the most beloved
deeds or acts of worship to allah the
ones which he made obligatory the ones
you have to do so you can argue that he
made them obligatory because he loves
them or he loves them because they're
obligatory regardless
if a muslim is able to and doesn't do
them then they are sinful for that and
you can find the benefits behind all
these things that got feeding the poor
obviously it's clear what the benefit is
praying and you know people talk about
meditation and stuff prayer salah is
actually a different level with the
different movements that we do and what
we recite and how it gives us a
different level of connection and
contentment with god
and going for hajj is a completely
mind-blowing experience which you can
only really testify to if you've been on
it and the brothers who have been to
hajj umrah can testify to that and
fasting ramadan which were in the
beautiful month
has many
beautiful benefits especially spiritual
spiritual benefits yeah
it's um
it goes
back to what i said
earlier in the podcast but it's
when the deeper you get into islam like
the more you see like everything has
reason
you know so it's like
okay you have these
these four other pillars aside from the
shahadah
like bro like yeah you you're sinful if
you don't do them and one might think
like oh damn i'm gonna become a muslim
and i'm gonna have to uphold myself to
all these things i'm gonna have to do
all this it's like
from the outside looking in like if
you're not doing it it looks like a lot
at first
but in reality it's not and then when
you do these things
again it's all for a reason you do these
things it brings you closer
to god the closer you are to god
the more at peace
you are
the more successful
you are in this life and in the next
like the better your character gets the
better you treat others the better
others treat you
the better your mental health everything
is just affected by this that's why it's
like
that's why we do this bro because it's
again it was
put upon us it's obligatory it's like
look this is what you have to do but
there was reason why you had to do this
it's like one of them is uh when you get
deeper into the quran it's like don't
drink alcohol like i said in in the
story with
what was going on like don't drink
alcohol
some someone might say that's a bad
thing but you you know how bad alcohol
can be if you drink it you know it's not
good for you it's
it's poisonous but like it's it's
poisoning your body
and
exactly bro but god understands that
he's created things and
some things there's
been and everything there's benefit and
there's there's harm right but in some
things there's more harm than benefit
and then other things there's more
benefit than harm and he
clarified that in alcohol there is
more harm than there is of benefit
and people know this very clearly you
know like someone might have social
anxiety
they might drink alcohol and it makes
them loosen up and they'll actually be
able to talk and have a good time and
not really experience the social anxiety
anymore but you know what
then they be they they start to build a
dependency on this
then
they um every time they go out now now
they have to drink a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more you
know and then it's like they they just
become crippled and
it just
they don't even know how to function
without it and then when they are on it
it doesn't work the same it doesn't have
the same effect so then
it's like
they just their social anxiety begins to
creep in even with the alcohol so
there was some benefit but the harm
further outweighed that and obviously
the physical
mental other stuff that's gonna occur
after that so
with this thing it's saying do not drink
alcohol
you can see it as a bad thing but in
reality it's
a good thing
and that's that's with everything bro
and allah writes in the quran too you
might like a thing which is bad for you
harmful for you
you know you might hate a thing which is
good for you bro but with that being
said bro
some couple months ago or a year ago two
years ago on a friday bro
you asked your meal that question we're
sitting here on a friday right now bro
yeah what's going on man tell us if
you're ready bro
this um
i'm a firm believer of um
of the present i'm meant to be here
right now today and i don't think it's a
it it wasn't it was not supposed to
happen so i believe that i am ready to
um
to start a new life and to
see where god takes me from here and i
know if i am to revert life won't be
easy you know life is not easy for
anyone but
um the hardships are put there for you
to grow and expand as a person
you know
so yeah i i feel good i'm nervous but um
i feel like no
all right well rami takes over for a bit
i'm just gonna change the live chat to
public so anyone can comment because
we're gonna we're gonna spam the
comments now bro but
take over
all right
so firstly i'm just gonna ask you a few
questions uh
to see if you believe what a muslim
should believe and if you have the
correct belief so just in case there's
anything missing we can correct it now
so do you believe
that there is one god worthy of worship
yes i do and do you believe that this
god is one alone without a second
without a husband wife father son
partners associates in any way yes i do
perfect do you believe
in the angels
yes i do
do you believe in the
books and the revelation that god has
sent
yes i do do you believe in the prophets
and messengers yes i do
do you believe in the day of judgment
life after death heaven and hell and
judgment from god yes i do
and do you believe in khadr which is
destiny and decree from god
yes i do
perfect masha allah and do you believe
that the quran is the unaltered word of
allah
yes i do masha allah okay so you're
going to repeat after me first what what
do you want to do in uh first you want
to do arabic or english first
um arabic first please christ okay
if i mess up the words in the way you
know yeah no worries bro
allah
after me in english i bear witness i
bear witness that there is no god worthy
of worship that there is no god worthy
of worship except allah except allah and
i bear witness and i'll be witness that
the prophet muhammad
that the prophet muhammad is the last
and final
is the last and final prophet and
messenger of god
prophet and messenger of god
allah
if i give you a hug right now i give you
a hug but i can't
no problem thank you
man yo so i got i got a few arabic names
if you want to choose we got jabril we
got uh ahmed we got now i'm just playing
with you
i was about to say didn't you say that i
have to change my name
since we don't have two too long i do
want to mention something it's actually
something that you mentioned which i
think is very beautiful which is
basically when
you're put in situations that are
difficult that are testing you that are
trying you
it's because it's meant to happen it's
supposed to make you better and the
prophet peace be upon him he actually
says in a hadith
that when allah loves a person
he tests them
now why is this because even even the
most atheistic person when they're
tested hard enough
when they're tried hard enough and the
challenge is difficult enough they will
call on god
and allah says in the quran he gives
basically a story of people traveling on
sea and the waves start to overtake
their ship so they start crying out to
god they start praying to allah
and when allah saves them
they turn back on their promise that
they made some of them uphold their
promise and others they turn back on it
yeah
so what i'm trying to get at here is as
a muslim
yes islam is going to be
beautiful islam is going to make your
life better in terms of your your life
here you're in your afterlife you're
going to live in sha allah the best
possible life because you're doing
exactly what you're created to to do
which is worship one god alone
but that doesn't mean that life is going
to be easy
it doesn't mean that life is going to be
a simple straightforward walk in the
park
there's it's it islam is a straight path
but shaytan is going to try and bring
you off of it and you will be tested and
you will be tried allah says in the
quran do you think you'll be left alone
saying we believe and you're not going
to be tested
so it's very important that as muslims
we we remember that even though we are
trying to establish the kingdom of god
on earth and that we believe what allah
has revealed uh to its purest form
insha'allah may allah keep us guided
it doesn't mean that everything is going
to be super easy i'm going to be rich
and i'm going to be famous and
everyone's going to love me
no but as long as allah loves you
and you'd enjoying good and forbid evil
then you will be successful in sha allah
thank you for that thank you happy of
course
just remember man a smooth seed never
made it say that
you know every hardship that you face
every trial that comes you just know
that it's
it was meant for you
and i think you already know this from
what you said
and brother like rami said it's so good
or it's like
a allah puts his hardship in our life
and it makes us see
like okay we really can't do anything
without allah so it's like in reality
like
this entire journey of life is just
coming back to allah so anytime that you
feel like you're experiencing extreme
hardship
ask yourself like are you
close to allah
or are you far from allah if you're far
from allah well then
it's clear sign for you to come back to
allah and if you're close to allah and
you're experiencing hardship
or but just know that allah really loves
you man because a lot of tests the ones
that he loves the most
just look at the prophets
peace
i've been smiling non-stop i wish i
could turn on my
camera eat it no no no you're good bro
you're good
you gotta keep the privacy yeah we'll
keep the privacy bro but listen we have
a group chat right that we've been
communicating through with you thus far
yeah keep this group strap group chat
going strong keep it alive bro anytime
you have any questions inquiries
clarifications anything you need from us
bro we're always here we'll regularly
check up on you we'll hit you up you
know after the stream is done and try to
give you some things you know to point
you in the right direction but as of now
bro your muslim bro take this day it's
friday you know um just enjoy it and uh
we'll talk about the next steps you know
how to pray all that stuff will come bro
inshallah
all right thank you thank you
of course of course and uh what a
beautiful time to take your shahadah as
well in the last 10 nights of ramadan in
the last few days of ramadan subhan
allah
absolutely beautiful masha'allah
so um
since we are in in ramadan and like
foreign
you have fasted before so i feel
comfortable saying this
i'm doing it now as well um you're doing
it now
and he's fasting too much that's so
beautiful
um
well
bro
i wanted to say this real quick too to
anyone they made it this far
um smash that like button share this
with someone that might need to hear it
um we partnered up with a masjid too if
you guys want to support that much that
they're going above and beyond and to
help they do the service they do to the
community helping those in need overseas
those that are less fortunate inshallah
links in the description to help them
out and to anyone that wants to support
the channel i think we got a comment
says if i do paypal from the website
can't donate from my country there's
probably a from country other than us i
don't know so from what i know anyone's
able to donate it's just the currency
that they give it is in usd so you can
donate from any country but you can
always dm us on instagram if you can't
pay through paypal and we can you know
show you how to do anything else like
cryptocurrency or direct deposit or
something else inshallah
ramirez i wanted you to answer one
question bro if you don't mind
yeah i'm just trying to find it
bro i want you to basically tell the
sister
you know what you would say to this
because i think it's not as bad as she
thinks it is and there's always hope
this made me tear up because i'm a
muslim but i haven't fasted even for one
day alhamdulillah the fact that this
makes you tear up is a beautiful thing
because there are people that claim to
be muslim that don't fast and don't care
and that person is worse than a person
that that doesn't fast and they know
they're wrong
and a person that doesn't believe they
they should fast actually may not even
be a muslim to begin with so
alhamdulillah at least let's first
acknowledge that you're in a much better
situation than maybe you were last year
and a lot better position than other
people are
and sister if it makes you tear up
then fast inshallah if you if it's too
late to smell fast today fast tomorrow
at least fast the last day or the last
two days of ramadan and push yourself
for the sake of allah and then make up
the days that you missed afterwards
if
you're going to wait till the winter
because you're going to wait to the
winter because days are shorter okay it
is what it is but make the intention of
making up the days for ramadan and the
sooner the better
and at least make the intention of
fasting next ramadan and insha'allah
you'll be you'll be tearing up with joy
instead of sadness
[Music]
it's all baby steps so at the end of the
day the fact that you're tearing up it
makes our day because we know that
there's something there bro that's fitra
you know when when you see that you see
real it shows that you got some realness
inside you just be real with yourself
too first and foremost before anyone
else on the internet too um you know
alhamdulillah that you were honest with
that but you don't need to tell anyone
you don't need to you know this is
between you and allah personal journey
just like it's going to be for brother
josh but start somewhere bro start with
or assist you know start with a few days
you know just do what you can and and
eventually work up to that and make the
intention just like romney said we're
not going to be the best muslim that we
can overnight right this is a message to
myself first and foremost too we're not
going to be the ideal perfect muslim or
muslim tomorrow
what is how can we just be one percent
better every day how can we get there
eventually
if you have that in mind then inshallah
we'll get there
yeah and i just want to throw in like
just like how rami said the fact that
you feel bad about it
that's good
because you know that how else can you
be sincere in your repentance you know
if you're asking allah for forgiveness
how can you be sincere if you don't
actually feel bad for it so the first
step in repentance is actually feeling
bad for what you're doing
so alhamdulillah you know
you do feel bad for it and just
go back to god go back to allah
ask for forgiveness
start fasting now you got a few days
left
it's never too late make it up when you
can
make the intention and then
that's it that's that's pretty much it
allah knows best what's in your heart
very beautifully said mashallah
[Music]
you got anything else you want to ask
no no um
i don't have anything else to ask
thank you very much
[Music]
bro as as the questions keep coming up
like feel free to ask in the group chat
because i mean you
trust like questions are gonna come up
that's all i got to say yeah yeah most
definitely i don't have questions at all
i need i need guidance you know um so
don't worry about that alhamdulillah
and guidance comes from allah you know
you may have a question that allah
answers for you in a way that maybe none
of us here could have could have given
you and maybe allah will answer the
question through us or use us
but regardless guidance comes from allah
we're coming up on german
uh very very shortly i think
inshallah let's rub it up then
[Music]
all
right masha'allah i almost don't want it
to end i'm just really happy
alhamdulillah
yeah
have you josh may allah bless you
immensely may allah and grant you the
best of this world and best in the next
invest this life and the best of the
hereafter
and uh welcome again to islam to the to
the brotherhood to the community to the
way the path of allah
these must clean the straight path
and
you guys have anything to add
before i wrap it up
no bro just wanted to say josh bro i
want to ask you are you still smiling
yeah yeah
yeah
bro i like keep that smile on your face
then with that light on your face and
only allow it to get brighter and and
shine on those around you to inspire
them too bro i mean and i've not only
impacted my own life but i've impacted
the lives of others who were who were in
the same situation as me
so definitely bro yeah how many
are we just watching the stream they're
also christian or they're also
considering to take the shahada and now
they feel more comfortable bro
yeah
oh thank you very much
alhamdulillah
the last thing that we want to say is
man like hey we love you for the sake of
allah and there's
there's a lot more people who love you
for the sake of a love brother song
welcome to the family
thank you
i feel welcome already you know i feel
at home already
a lot of work that i need to do myself
except from him his good deeds and
elevate him in this life in the next
with that being said
to